jumping into just cause
i believe you are writing that yeah yeah
so how close are we to finally getting
some you know
announcements what's going on with that
project honestly
next couple of weeks um i think there
will be a casting announcement
and there will be a um you know the
general overlay as to where we stand but
uh
that was with constantine and adrian
iscaria and uh
it's awesome it's so much michael daus
directing
um and you know i love about it is uh
a lot of times when you adapt a video
game and ip there's either
not enough to adapt or way too much and
with him it was like
dude you watched the trailer for just
cause four and you're like
i got it i get it let's go you know and
it's a joy man
right so the script is then done yeah
yeah yeah
um is it like is everyone happy where
that's like the shooting script like
you're close
yeah i mean but i mean to be honest like
everything changes in the next two weeks
in regards to
casting and timing and production and
all that kind of stuff um but where we
are right now
and you know you know douse did a
director's pass and
you know he he's he's got it rendered
down to what he wants to shoot but
you know better than most that as soon
as you cast and you see you higher
people start picking out those cards and
you're like let's open up a new deck and
build it from the ground up
and yet uh the core is there and there
are elements and structural things that
just won't change because we like them
you know
how is this going to be a
a great or good video game movie
well we stay with the character you know
i think that's the big one is we we
we have we have the action we have the
set pieces we have the
atmosphere you have the bad guys you
have the the toys and all those things
we love about the game
but we stick with a character and he's
cool you know and
you care about him and you want to see
more of them i mean one of the
characters
lately that has been intriguing more
than most has been the mandalorian and
the fact that
you don't see his face it seems very
simple and yet you find him endearing
for a murdering bounty hunter right
uh and with this guy it's very much a um
it's a hero's journey it's it's an
indiana jones by way of bond
uh and you know that's all the way
always the way they sold the games and
why we played the games
but we meet him at a point where he
is shifting gears do you up shift or
downshift
and that's where you love to that's
where you love to see a character
and as a franchise progresses you want
to you want to see that shift or slip
you know you want to build them up break
them down and build them up again and
that guy's a fun one to do it with